fear and anger are what drove me to take
action like I didn't have a lot of faith
I had a lot of anger and it took me
years to like even switch to not always
being driven by anger and trying to
prove people wrong and I wouldn't say
that I'm purely Faith driven now I would
say that I have elements of it I just
don't know if it's a binary for me I
would just say that over time I have
less of that and I have more of some
other stuff I enjoy what I do now a lot
trying to find what the fuel is now I
don't think about it much I just do the
things that I enjoy that I've been
rewarded for doing in the past I work
hard on things because the harder I work
on things the better things tend to work
out for me